Nosotros ya hemos visto a qué nos referimos,
cuando estamos tratando de sacar
64 elevado a la potencia 1/3 ¿ok?
Y esto lo que significa
es simplemente que tenemos que encontrar
la raíz cúbica del número 64.
¿Ok? O sea tenemos que encontrar un número que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 3 veces nos da 64.
Ahora por otro lado,
nosotros sabemos que si tomamos el 4
y lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 3 veces,
o sea multiplicamos 4, por 4, por 4
o sea elevamos el 4 a la tercera potencia,
lo que obtenemos es 4 por 4 = 16
por 4 = 64.
Entoncesm esto nos dice que 4 es justo ese número que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 3 veces...
3 veces, nos da 64, así es que esta raíz cúbica de 64
es igual a 4 o sea 64
elevado a la 1/3 es 4.
Ahora, lo que vamos a hacer ahorita, es hacer esto mismo,
pero un poquito más complicado aunque con exponentes más complejos,
aquí este exponente es una fracción
pero su numerador es un 1,
y eso es justo lo que vamos a cambiar ¿ok?
Ahora nos interesa saber qué pasa
cuando queremos encontrar
64 elevado a la potencia 2/3,
¿Ok? Y para hacer eso,
vamos a usar una propiedad de los exponentes,
que vamos a ver más a fondo más adelante
pero, que podemos ver rápidamente ahorita.
Digamos con un número sencillo, pongamos
por ejemplo un 2,
ok, tenemos aquí el 2
y digamos que tenemos elevado este 2 a la potencia 3,
y después todo este nuevo número que es 2 a la 3,
que es 8, lo tenemos elevado a la potencia 4,
¿ok? hay una propiedad de los exponentes
que nos dice que este número
es igual a tomar la base, que es este número 2,
y elevarlo a la potencia 3 por 4 ¿ok?
3 por 4 es 12, entonces esto es igual a
tomar el 2 y elevarlo a la potencia 12.
Ok, tenemos un número,
ese número lo estamos elevando a la potencia 3,
y luego todo ese númerote lo estamos elevando a la potencia 4,
y eso es exactamente igual a tomar ese número,
que es el 2 y elevarlo a la potencia de...
esta potencia, por esta potencia,
o sea 3 por 4 que es 12.
Bueno pero esto lo podemos ver también como
2 elevado a la potencia 4 por 3,
y esto lo podemos ver como, hacer digamos lo inverso a lo que hicimos aquí.
Esto lo podemos ver como 2 elevado a la 4
y todo eso elevado a la 3.
Y bueno, justo esto es lo que queremos usar por acá,
porque 2/3 lo podemos ver como
1/3 multiplicado por 2 ¿no?
Entonces esto de aquí lo podemos ver como 64
elevado a la potencia 1/3
y después todo esto elevado al cuadrado,
porque mira,
64 elevado a la 1/3
y después al cuadrado es igual a
64 elevado a la 1/3 por 2
y eso es exactamente igual a
64 elevado a las 2/3.
Entonces estas 2 cosas son iguales,
pero nosotros ya sabemos cuánto vale,
64 elevado a la 1/3  lo tenemos por aquí...
Entonces 64 elevado a la 2/3 es 64,
elevado a la 1/3,
que es como vimos por aquí, 4...
4, esto es igual a 4 y después tenemos que elevarlo
al cuadrado... al cuadrado ¿ok?
64 a la 2/3 es 4 al cuadrado,
que es 4 por 4 = 16.
Ahora como yo lo pienso,
es tal cual tengo aquí la expresión,
64 a la 2/3
y yo sin tener que escribir todo esto, simplemente digo,
64, vamos a tomar primero la raíz cúbica...
raíz cúbica de 64 es 4
y después elevamos al cuadrado,
entonces 4 al cuadrado es 16 y listo.
Bueno vamos con otro problema,
este problema te recomiendo que lo hagas tú solito,
y ya después cheques lo que hicimos nosotros como solución, y voy a tratar de ponerle colores bonitos.
Entonces a ver, 8 entre 27
elevado a la -2/3
¿Ok? Así es que ya sabes ponle pausa, hazlo tú
en tu cuaderno y luego lo pones play.
Bueno vamos a resolverlo paso a paso.
Aquí para hacer esto lo primero que hago es fijarme en el signo del exponente, aquí tenemos un menos
y esto lo que nos dice es que tomemos el recíproco
de la base ¿Ok? O sea tomemos 1 entre 8 entre 27
y eso lo único que hace es cambiar el numerador con el denominador,
o sea que aquí nos queda
27 entre 8 y el exponente
lo dejamos tal cual,
pero en su forma positiva, ok, ya no va a ser - 2/3,
va a ser simplemente 2/3,
Así es que aquí nos queda elevado a la potencia 2/3.
¿Y cómo le vamos a hacer para resolver esto?
Pues vamos a usar una propiedad
de los exponentes super importante que ya vimos,
que lo que nos dice es que si tenemos una fracción
elevada a otro exponente,
eso es igual a
tomar el numerador
y elevarlo al exponente,
o sea elevar 27 a la 2/3
y dividirlo entre el denominador...
denominador...
elevado a la misma potencia,
o sea elevarlo a la 2/3.
Bueno, ahora lo que tenemos que hacer, es ver qué significan cada una de estas expresiones,
y para hacer eso vamos a usar esto mismo
que acabamos de ver.
Esta otra propiedad de la siguiente forma.
¿Ok? Tenemos por aquí
27 elevado a la potencia 2/3
eso por esta propiedad es
exactamente igual
a 27 elevado a la 1/3
y luego todo este número
elevado al cuadrado
y lo mismo le pasa a este 8 a la 2/3,
esto es exactamente igual a 8
elevado a la 1/3
y luego todo este número,
elevado al cuadrado.
Y ahora sí ya podemos resolver cada una de
estas cosas, por que para encontrar
27 a la 1/3  lo único que tenemos que hacer
es encontrar ese número,
que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo
3 veces, nos da 27.
Y seguramente te viene a la cabeza
justo el número adecuado
porque 3 por 3, por 3,
o sea 3 multiplicado por sí mismo 3 veces
es igual a 3 por 3 = 9 por 3 = 27.
Entonces este número de aquí,
la raíz cúbica de 27
es igual a 3,
entonces, este numerador se convierte en 3 elevado al cuadrado,
porque este 3 es igual
a lo que está dentro de este paréntesis,
y este paréntesis lo estamos elevando al cuadrado.
Y bueno, lo mismo pasa con el denominador.
Tenemos 8 elevado a la 1/3,
estamos buscando entonces la raíz cúbica de 8
y ese número, a ver dime ¿cuál es?
Pues tenemos que 2 por 2 por 2 es 8.
Entonces 8 elevado a la 1/3,
o sea lo que está dentro de estos paréntesis es un 2
pero, estamos elevando a 8 a la 1/3 al cuadrado.
Entonces por aquí nos queda 2 al cuadrado.
¡Y Listo!
Ya terminamos de encontrar este número ¿Ok?
3 al cuadrado es 9
y lo estamos dividiendo entre 2 al cuadrado,
que es 4,
Muy bien.
Entonces ya viste si organizamos
nuestras ideas de una forma adecuada
y usamos las propiedades de los exponentes,
estos números se vuelven súper sencillos.